thanks a lot thanks a lot for inviting
me here this based on joint work with
Olivia basket of Moses Jericho and uncle
Moitra I guess since this is the post
lunch session of the last day of the
workshop I'll try to keep the majority
of the talk light rate to stop in any
point if you have any questions so I
guess I mean this is a workshop on
tensors so you don't need any
introduction to it but let me just set
the notation that I will use in this
talk so we'll be looking at tensors so
of order two three I mean order three
and above so the order of the tensor is
just the dimensionality of the tensor
and the size of the tensor is typically
represented in terms of n so this three
tensor for instance has size n cross n
cross N and typically we'll want
guarantees in terms of this size N and
all the elements of the tensor are over
reals okay so no finite fields it's just
over else and this talk is going to be
about low rank decompositions of tensors
we'll say that a tensor has a tensor T
has rank K if it can be written as a sum
of K rank one tensors okay so where a
rank 1 tensor is just the order product
of vectors and the rank of a tensor is
just the smallest K such that I mean
such a rank a decomposition exists
and yeah I mean you're all familiar with
tensors so the rank of a P tensor can go
up to N to the P minus 1 and right so in
this talk will not just be looking at
low rank decomposed exact lower rank
decomposers of tensors we'll also be
looking at low rank approximations in
the sense that typically we will be
given a tensor and the tensor may not
have an exact rank a decomposition it
may have a rank a decomposition that
approximate that approximates it in
Frobenius norm up to some error okay and
what we want to find are usually
decompositions which will approach which
will come close to the tensor it may not
give you exactly the tensor but it
should come close to the tensor up to
some error and we will usually measure
the error and Frobenius norm so I guess
the reason why a lot of us are
interested intensity compositions in the
computer science community and in the
statistics community is because of these
remarkable results about uniqueness of
density compositions and I mean I guess
there are a lot of such results let me
give you some of the highlights the
first search results that I know is due
to Harshman and basically the result
states that if you have a 3 tensor with
a rank a decomposition such that the
individual vectors of the decomposition
are linearly independent then this
decomposition is unique and in fact he
gave an algorithm to find this
decomposition in polynomial time and
this is what we call the full trying
case and this algorithm has been
rediscovered many times in different
communities so so because we want these
vectors to be linearly independent this
can typically handle the case when the
rank K is at most n the dimensional
okay so and in the previous talk we
looked at this remarkable result due to
Crisco
we showed that these rank a decomposed
urns for three tensors and higher order
tensors typically unique under some mild
conditions which I call these rank
conditions and I mean I won't go into
the exact condition but usually they
imply uniqueness for three tenses up to
rank three and over two so instead of n
it can go up to three and over to and
for P tensors you can get a natural
generalization of it and it will show
uniqueness of density compositions of P
tensors for rank up to P times n over
two and okay so these were results for
general tensors which satisfy these
conditions and as we have seen a lot in
the first day of the workshop there are
results that are known generically much
better results that are known
generically so you can hope for
uniqueness for three tensors up to rank
n square over three and I mean these two
results are non algorithmic results the
first result was algorithmic and
similarly you can also obtain an
algorithmic result for four tensors of
rank up to something constant times n
square but these are generic results
they are not worst-case results
and this can also be generalized to beat
order tensors so in this talk we will
will will want polynomial time
algorithms for tensor decompositions
when the ranked is typically much rather
than the dimension in okay so this is
np-hard in the worst case except for
some special settings and this is due to
Hiller and limp and in this talk what we
will do is we will we will design
polynomial time algorithms which are
actually robust in the sense that they
also work to give these low-rank
approximation to tensor so they can
handle errors in the tensor and we will
we will show how we can design
polynomial time algorithms where the
rank is much larger than the dimension
and using smooth analysis so and in the
stop you not we not actually handle the
case when the order the tensor is three
our results will kick in when the order
is 5 and above and yeah by polynomial
time algorithms what I mean is
algorithms that take time which is
polynomial in n the rank K K is usually
related as a polynomial to N and the
accuracy parameter okay if you want to
recover that vectors individual vectors
of the decomposition up to epsilon error
in the Frobenius norm l2 norm because
these are vectors oh great so poly P it
just means that it is polynomial in n
but it could have a bad dependence on P
for instance n to the P is poly P it
could be in fact some of our results
will be n to the exponential in P but as
long as P is fixed as long as P is a
small constant these are polynomial time
so will just hide the dependence on P
because P is a small constant
and nestled dog first I mean we have
seen a lot of the applications of these
density compositions to machine learning
but let me just give you a very brief
overview because these will this will
motivate some of the properties that we
want from our algorithms okay and this
is also motivate the smooth analysis
model that we will consider for tensity
compositions and then I will introduce
the smoothness model and I will tell us
a tell your board or algorithmic results
in the smoothed analysis model and
finally I will give you some flavor of
the techniques that we use in the proof
so what goes into the proof yeah I mean
if we saw this in the first set I mean
in the morning session and I mean I
think something that's done very
frequently in machine learning is to
assume that the data that's given to you
comes from this nice probabilistic model
that is very suitable for the task at
hand
for instance we looked at mixtures of
gaussians this is a really nice
probabilistic model for clustering when
you have pic K clusters and you assume
that points come from these clusters and
you want to do this clustering so you
try to fit a good mixture of Gaussian
model to points that you see in n
dimensions if similarly hidden Markov
models are used for speech recognition
and and so on and the goal here is
suppose you are given many samples that
are produced according to this model can
you learn the parameters of this model
efficiently efficiently I want
algorithms that take running time that's
polynomial in N and the sample
complexity also has to be polynomial
then just because the running time is
polynomial okay so one particular case
that we will look at is the mixtures of
gaussians this is similar to mixtures of
spherical gaussians these are called
axis aligned gaussians and here the
parameters of the model are the mixing
weights W 1 through W ok so this will
tell you the probability that a random
sample belongs to that mean Gaussian one
is given by the mixing weight W 1 okay
and the parameters of each of these
Gaussian so each Gaussian has his own
mean mu I and a covariance Sigma
covariance matrix Sigma I which is
diagonal this is why it's called
an axis aligned Gaussian so if this
Gaussian was
I mean if this covariance matrix was
actually just a scalar times I then it's
a spherical calcium and the points are
generated as follows this is an N
dimensions so first a random sample you
you figure out which Gaussian okay so
with probability WI the point is going
to be generated according to the
Gaussian I conditioned on the fact that
you are generating the sample according
to Gaussian I you pick a random point
with mean mu I and covariance Sigma okay
so you first pick the Gaussian according
to the mixing weights and then a point
is generated according to this Gaussian
and you see many of these samples and
the question is given many sample points
can you figure out the mixing weights
the means and the covariances okay and
known algorithms take time that is
exponential in the number of clusters
exponential in K times polynomial in n
yeah and in fact in the worst case this
is essentially the best possible this
exponential in K dependence is necessary
okay but what we what we want a
polynomial and K comma n guarantees in
some realistic settings or under some
assumptions so that's what our
algorithms for tensity compulsions will
also imply and so I mean yeah so the
reason why tensity compositions come in
is due to the method of moments so this
is like this general principle towards
designing algorithms using tensity
compositions for learning many of these
flow elastic models I mean just to tell
you briefly it consists of two steps the
first step is to figure out is to figure
out the tensor okay to compute a tensor
from the samples which will have a
decomposition which exactly encodes some
model parameters okay so you want this
decomposition to typically have low rank
for instance if you have a mixture of k
gaussians you want this tensor to have K
rank one terms when there is one rank
one term for each of the gaussians okay
so for instance if you look at the
mixtures of gaussians problem you can
look at the third moment tensor okay and
you can massage it a bit
and you can get a tensor which is
exactly rank K okay if you had infinite
samples but you'll get it up to some
accuracy so which will be rank K with 1
Rank 1 term for each of the gaussians so
Mui here is the mean of the Gaussian at
the second step is to just use
off-the-shelf algorithms about tensile
decompositions so if you have a
uniqueness result for tensile
decompositions this implies that by
looking at the third moments you can
uniquely recover the parameters of the
model and if you have a polynomial time
algorithm for the decomposition then you
actually get efficient polynomial time
algorithms for learning as well so a lot
of the creativity I mean a lot of work
goes into figuring out this tensor which
encodes the model parameters ok but I
mean modulo that you can just use any
off-the-shelf algorithm for tensity
compositions to come up with learning
algorithms
ok so this is some this I mean this is
some framework that was established by a
long line of work starting from Joseph
Chang and I mean there's been a lot of
work recently in the spectral learning
area it's been pioneered by Shankar
today Daniel Hsu and so on so so here we
we computed this tensor and I mean using
these samples by looking at the third
moment for instance and we were hoping
to use algorithms for tensor
decompositions on the stencil okay but
we are computing these this tensor from
samples so there's always sampling error
so if you are using capital n number of
samples okay so if you typically get
term wise errors which are 1 over square
root of capital n so if you only see
polynomially many samples you can only
get the tensor up to inverse polynomial
error in the Frobenius norm so what you
want our uniqueness results for tensor
decompositions and algorithms for
density compositions
okay which is robust to noise which is
inverse polynomial ok so this is our
goal if we want the sensory composure
are useful for learning okay we want
these tensor decomposition results
either uniqueness or algorithms which is
robust to inverse polynomial noise and
so we saw this algorithm due to Hirshman
which is actually in tricks algorithm
and end-rigs algorithm actually gives
you a polynomial time algorithm for
decomposing tensors of rank at most n ok
so this rank at most n actually comes in
doodoo condition that we will see
earlier it is actually phrased in terms
of the minimum singular value of a
certain matrix ok and this polynomial
time algorithm is actually robust to
inverse polynomial error and using the
desapeared I mentioned earlier so you
can use this as a black box to define to
design efficient algorithms for learning
various throttle stick models when the
number of clusters in the Gaussian or in
the number of topics is at most a
dimension so this is something this is
exactly what shankar kadai eluded to in
the morning talk so this is very useful
in in many cases but there quite a few
cases when the number of clusters or
topics is much rather than the dimension
so this comes up in applications like
computer vision or speech okay and if
you want these polynomial I mean these
algorithms for tensity compositions to
hold in these settings you want
polynomial time algorithms for
decomposing tensors whose rank is much
larger than n so that's the goal of this
talk but this is np-hard in the worst
case ok so what we'll do is we will use
smooth analysis ok so this is one way
this will allow us to go beyond
worst-case analysis the worst case
intractability ok and smooth analysis is
beautiful paradigm that was introduced
by spin when anything the in fact won
the Goodell prize for this for this work
and they used smooth dances to explain
why the simplex algorithm solves linear
programs very efficiently in practice
so smooth they're as good smooth
analysis guarantees will tell you that
the bad instances for the algorithm are
essentially isolated so if you really
think of you know mapping this whole
instance space and you you you draw a
graph that plots the running time for
your algorithm on these instances then
you'll see these Peaks that correspond
to bad instances okay but these bad
instance these Peaks are essentially
isolated and the way you show this is by
saying that if you if you if you apply a
small random perturbation to the input
okay then your algorithm runs quickly in
polynomial time with high probability
that means they'll piece a lower
dimensional it's not cute at the
isolated points right only their lower
division things right so they're not
isolated points it's just that these
these sets are very small measure but
you can't have a big chunk of space
which is bad okay so this is what smooth
analysis guarantees will will imply so
if you look at any instance in a small
ball around it most of the instances are
easy okay so these bad instances really
need to be yeah fairly small and
disconnected
so these are the best kind of guarantees
that you can hope for in the absence of
worst-case guarantees okay because you
can mean you can you can vary the amount
of the perturbation so so we'd be
looking at smooth analysis but for
learning and for tensor decompositions
so before we go into the smooth dialysis
model for tensity compositions let's
look at that the smooth the natural
smooth that is model for learning
because this will this will inspire our
model for density compositions so if you
look at this mixtures of gaussians
problem the worst case for the mixtures
of gaussians problem comes up when these
means the mean vectors lie in certain
pathological configurations like for
example when these means lie on a line
okay but these means are not an
adversarial configuration in the real
world okay so so what if you slightly
perturbed each of the means we want to
show that if you slightly perturbed each
of the means then the problem actually
becomes easy the mixtures of gaussians
which are generated according to the
slightly perturb means is actually easy
so this is what we would want to show in
the learning setting so what about the
analogue is smooth their answers model
for tensor d compositions you remember
for that for the mixtures of gaussians
problem we had this tensor where the
individual the vectors in the
decomposition were comprised of the
means so in the natural smooth and also
small for tensity compositions you will
assume that these vectors of the
decomposition are slightly perturbed
okay so this is a this is a smoothness
model so suppose I mean you're given a
tensor T okay well the vectors are the
decomposition of these AIS but you're
not going to analyze your algorithm on
this tensor you're going to analyze your
algorithm on a different tensor which is
which has its vector so the
decomposition being slightly perturbed
so you're going to show that your
algorithm runs with type I mean in
polynomial time with high probability on
this tensor T tilde where T tilde the
vectors of the decomposition T tilde are
these AI tildes which are perturbed
versions of a is okay and you'll also
have some noise because we want to
tolerate some inverse polynomial noise
this is a smooth analysis small for
tensor decompositions that we will study
there's such a thing as symmetric
perturbation you're starting with a
symmetric tensor oh yeah yeah that's a
great question
so in fact we would ideally want to
handle perturbations to only these new
ice in fact this is what we will do but
yeah I mean yeah for in the case of
symmetric tensors we will handle the
case when these perturbations are just
to the mew ice and you have the same
perturbation across I mean all these
vectors because symmetric but I mean
when we do an analysis we will actually
think of these as different vectors and
we can't do that because you I mean
because the order is constant you can
actually just partition the coordinates
and you can think of an independent
random perturbation to each of these
even in the case of symmetric tensors
here right so you can think of it as
just this random perturbation applied to
Mui
so I mean just to clarify things about
this model is actually different okay so
in smoother analysis you put up the
input instance and here the input is a
tensor that's given to you okay so the
perturbation that I mentioned where you
perturb the terms of the decomposition
the vectors in the recom portion is
different from perturbing the elements
of the tensor that's given to you so for
instance if you are given a tensor
you cannot perturb it and apply your
results so you can you cannot apply the
perturbation yourself so the assumption
is that the vectors of the bird the
vectors of the decomposition are
actually perturbed so the learning
problem for instance we are assuming
that the means of these gaussians were
perturbed so this is different from
getting samples and perturbing the
samples to figure out your tension
and and the reason why I think smooth
analysis results of this kind are a very
relevant to this workshop is because
they mean they are very similar in
spirit to these dynamic results because
I mean one way that you can say that
your algorithm typically runs in
polynomial time is by thinking of an
average case distribution over instances
and showing that your algorithm runs
with high probability in polynomial time
over this distribution okay but in that
case in average case analysis you can
have this big chunk of hard instances
and as long as the measure or the
probability mass on this chunk is less
than an inverse polynomial amount you're
fine but this could actually be like a
big chunk a good connected chunk of
instances but smooth analysis
I mean smooth analysis results will show
that I mean will say that such chunks
cannot exist good smooth their answers
yourself will say that these kind of big
chunks cannot exist and that's because
you look at any instance and if you look
at a small ball around it most of those
instances are easy so in this sense it
is more similar in spirit to generic
results than average case analysis but
in some sense you can think of these
smooth analysis results as a natural
analogue for you know these kind of
robust results that we are hoping for
and what kind of guarantee is to be sure
we give polynomial time algorithms for
decomposing feet order tensors so they
have size into the peak when the rank is
up to N to the P minus 1 over 2 that's
the floor of n to the P minus 1 over 2
okay with with high priority so the
failure probability is exponentially
small in n and the running time and
sample complexity are polynomial in N
so just for a comparison these the
previous algorithms could work in the
regime where the rank was at most n is
the rank is at most n but using smooth
analysis we can actually cover a much
larger range so you can cover a range
where the rank goes up to n to the P
minus 1 over 2 it's a floor here so when
P is 5 it can cover it can go up to a
rank being n square constant times n
square
okay
and as a corollary just using the recipe
that I mentioned earlier you can also
get polynomial time algorithms for
learning various tralala stick models
like mixtures of spherical gaussians or
axis aligned gaussians and topic models
and so on
when the number of clusters of in a
number of topics is any polynomial in
the dimension the dimension here is n
and you can handle any polynomial in the
dimension because you just choose the
order of the tensor to be you know a
sufficiently large constant
okay any questions about the guarantees
in the range way we know that the
problem is np-hard
yes yes exactly yeah and this is where
smooth analysis helps us
so you're saying
it's better than average you're saying
it's not such a hard problem right so
yeah I guess this problem is very hard
in the worst case right so so I mean can
you repeat what he said I mean it is
miss food analysis guarantees also tell
you naturally that the average case
version of the problem is also easy yeah
right right yeah no I mean smooth Downs
is beautiful motion that experiment they
came up with because I mean so if you
look at the guarantees that we get okay
so you get this time and sample
complexity is polynomial in P and 1 over
Rho now you can you can alter Rho to get
a nice interpolation between worst case
and average case so if you think of Rho
as being zero in which case it's worst
case you don't get any results okay
because this this exponent is just a
constant and you know it works with
probability zero but if you think of Rho
as being very large then it gets more
and more like an average case model you
know in like random instances so what we
show is that we can actually handle
handle the case when the amount of
perturbation is inverse polynomial in n
so if it's inverse polynomial end you
still have polynomial time guarantees
let's say that there was also another
independent work due to Anderson Belkin
well brother marker and boss who share
similar guarantees who also looked at a
smooth analysis model for tensor
decompositions actually more for
learning problems like mixtures of
gaussians and the kind of guarantees
that they get are slightly incomparable
okay so they also get polynomial time
guarantees as long as the failure
probability that they want is inverse
polynomial so just to compare we can get
polynomial time guarantees where the
failure probability is exponentially
small and this is nice because you know
you are given just one instance and you
want to you want your algorithm to work
you know on all instances that you
potentially see okay but on the other
hand they actually get better
dependences on the order of the tensor P
so they are incomparable in that sense
so so in the necessary talk let me tell
you a little bit about the details of
the algorithm okay so the outline of the
algorithm is as follows okay so I left
two parts okay so first we will just
look at an algorithm for three tenses in
the full drank setting okay so this is
something that was known earlier let me
just go over it very briefly okay so we
will use an algorithm that is that works
for three tensors in the case when the
rank is at most n it is the vectors of
the decomposition are linearly
independent in a robust sense and for
such tensors we will show that we can
actually recover the vectors of the
decomposition okay so so just to lay
down some notation suppose you have this
tensor T where you have these rank 1
vectors B and the heighth rank 1 tensor
is given by AI tensor product with bi
tensor product CI ok so then you can
associate these matrices a B and C where
the vectors of your decomposition or the
columns of this matrix okay so this is
the same matrix that are the theory used
in the stock so here
the ith column of this matrix a is
exactly AI
similarly the ith column of matrix B is
B a and C a and we will show that you
know there is a simple algorithm this
algorithm do to n again trick it
actually works
when the kids smallest singular value of
a B and C is at least inverse polynomial
men
so this is just Pauline end so case
mister noon ok so just because we want
Sigma care to be non-negligible
this can only handle the cases when K is
at most n so this is the first component
and in the second step we will show how
you can actually solve higher order
tensors using what is actually I mean
this is something that is being used a
lot in practice it's just I mean not in
the past which is flattening the tensor
so we will treat this higher order
tensor the speed-up peeth order tensor
as a third order tensor by flattening
some of the dimensions and we will show
that by flattening you get these nice
properties like linear independence in
this higher dimensional space so that we
can use this algorithm for three tensors
so that's the outline algorithm or shine
okay and so this will handle help handle
the over complete case and you know
being you could have actually used any
algorithm for tensor decomposition the
full rank sitting here so you could have
you could have also done this step of
whitening and applying power iteration
yes yeah it's to show that when you
flatten you want to show that these
vectors in the decomposition are
linearly independent
oh but I see but for fifth order tensor
can continue show hardness for rank
being something like linear and n yeah
you go the six and indeed I also have
the same question it's quite low so okay
so I guess one one thing that I guess
the king is here so he's the expert on
the hardness results right so for third
order tensors the rank is roughly 6n and
hardness and is it linear in n even for
higher order tensors is it you know is
it hard even for rank being some
constant times n may be constant I mean
you can always think of a degenerate
higher order tensor which corresponds to
the third order tensor and that is
np-hard just because the third order
tensor is np-hard yeah but I mean yeah I
mean I mean okay yeah I mean this needs
checking whether you know there's an
interesting case of a higher order
tensor which is also np-hard
because you can think of degenerate
cases but I mean I would guess that it's
np-hard in the regime where it's not
unique though and we know that
uniqueness only holds when the run goes
up to
P n over 2 I would guess that it is
something larger than P n over 2 but I'm
not sure what the exact rank is for
these interesting cases no no a worst
case I mean specific condition and like
critical conditions
so so first we will look at an algorithm
for three tenses and then we do this
flattening okay so what's the algorithm
for three tenses asleep I mean let me
just go go into the algorithm okay so
it's very simple so you just think of
your tensor as being I mean it's a three
tensor so you can just think of them as
slices which are matrices okay so if
it's an N cross n cross and tensor just
think of them as n slices of n cross n
matrices okay so now you're going to
look at two matrices okay so the first
one you just get by one random
combination of all these slices okay so
that's matrix M 1 so that random
combination is given by W 1 okay and
then you look at a different random
combination of all these slices so
that's m2 I just look at m1 times m2
pseudo-inverse and you can show that the
eigenvectors of this matrix this is not
a symmetric matrix so you look at the
eigenvectors of this matrix this is
correspond to the vectors in your
decomposition so note that this is not
singular vectors these are eigenvectors
of the matrix which will correspond to
the vectors of your decomposition so
this is CN Rick's algorithm
so and what do we want brief basically
because you're looking at eigenvectors
you want this matrix to be full rank
okay so you want these matrices a B and
C to be full rank so that you can
recover each of these vectors this is
why you need the vectors of your
decomposition to be linearly independent
and mean yeah and basically you want
some separation between the eigenvalues
so that when you'll get them distinctly
and this is why random combinations work
but typically I mean I mean any
combination any sensible combination it
should work and you can show that this
also works robustly by using some
standard perturbation bounds on
eigenvalues and eigenvectors okay and
you can show that this algorithm
actually works when the tensor is given
up to inverse polynomial error in the
Frobenius norm okay so this equal to
epsilon this means t minus this tensor
Frobenius norm is less than Epsilon
exactly yes so this only works in the
full track case when K is less than an
intruder and I mean one thing that helps
is that me you don't need a B and C to
be full rank okay so you just need two
of them to be full rank the third one
just needs all the vectors to not be
parallel to each other I mean this is
just some you know this will just give
you some small improvement so this is n
tricks algorithm and you can get robust
guarantees for this okay and so let's
see how we can handle the high at the
higher rank case you are using
flattening because how do we yeah K less
wrinkled on oh I see why do you why why
do we handle K less than a grand oh okay
okay okay okay good so this is because
you can do the pseudo-inverse I mean you
you look at the pseudo-inverse more
penrose yeah yeah
so another thing that you can do is the
following
okay so what you can do is you can just
look at so you can figure out the space
of the a is the B is and the C is
approximately by just doing the mean you
just look at you can take random
combinations of over the sea ice and you
get this matrix and you do an s-video
over it so that will give you a
k-dimensional space now you can put this
whole tensor this N cross n cross n
tensor into a K cross K cross K tensor
after by doing this rotation and then
you can just imagine that the rank is
exactly K okay so this analysis is
actually easier to do yes yes you're
projecting it into the space where these
vectors like and that is K dimensional
because it's independent okay so this is
I mean in fact the procedure that I told
you is exactly what we analyzed in our
paper okay so I mean you know I think
this this algorithm also works and I
think the algorithm due to coil when
Paula and Chavo actually deal with this
but I'm not sure
so how do we handle higher-ranked case
we do this by flattening okay so what do
we have here we have the higher order
tensor let's say the order is 6 so what
do we mean by flattening so what you're
going to do is we are going to we are
going to think of this we are going to
combine some of these dimensions
together you're going to think of this
sixth order tensor as a third order
tensor by combining the first two modes
or dimensions this the third and fourth
more than the fifth and six more so this
n cross n cross n cross n cross n tensor
can be seen as this n square cross n
square plus n square third order tensor
and what are the terms of the
decomposition the terms of decomposition
are exactly ái tensor bi there are K of
them CI tensor di and di 1005 okay so we
have this n square cross n square cross
n square third order tensor which has
images of rank K s and these are the
terms were decomposed and these vectors
are in n square or n square so now if
you want to apply the earlier algorithm
the main thing that we need to show is
that these vectors AI tensor be I okay
when you go from I going from 1 to K are
linearly independent
remember that they lie in a n Square
dimensional space
so I mean ideally you could hope for all
these vectors to be linearly independent
given when K is constant times n square
okay so this is what we would like to
show okay so I mean just to just to
repeat what I said earlier so you have
these two matrices a and B which have
rank n okay but they have many more
columns K is something like n square
some constant times n square okay what
we wanted what we want to analyze this
suppose you take that I mean you
construct a new matrix Z okay
whereas the ight column is exactly the
tensor product of the ID column of a and
the ID column of B okay so you now get
this large matrix with an N square cross
K K is also roughly and square so I mean
these were initially very fat matrices
and now you have made them roughly
square and you want to show that these
vectors are now linearly independent
even for K being constant times n square
so unfortunately this is not true okay
so you can come up with bad examples
where even for K being greater than 2 n
when you do this tensor ring trick they
are not linearly independent anymore in
fact a very simple example is suppose
you come you think of this matrix a is
coming from you know as having two
pieces the first n columns come from one
orthonormal basis and the second and
columns come from a different
orthonormal basis with the random
rotation then you can then show that if
you look at this operation applied to
itself so AI tensor a is and if you look
at these columns they're not going to be
linearly independent in
I mean it's just a very simple counter
example so this shows that you cannot
hope to I mean you cannot hope for the
dimension of this tensor that you've got
by applying this operation this
operation by the way where you do this
term wise tensor product of columns is
called the cut reroute product so I mean
and you cannot hope that the dimension
increases multiplicatively using the cut
reader product in the worst case okay
but this is why we use smooth analysis
because these bad examples are kind of
pathological and even if you try to come
up with them it's kind of hard to and
the hope is that typically you can hope
for this dimension to multiply but then
if you I mean it only becomes worse
again right because what you want to do
is you have a very fat matrix you want
to make it as square as possible because
you want all the vector mean columns to
be linearly independent so if you take
the chronica product it's still going to
be very fast
so this is what we will show okay so
what we will show us that if you look if
you take any matrix a ok which is n
cross K K is very large case a large
polynomial in N and if you take the P
wise cut reader product if you take the
country or product P times so the ith
column of this matrix is just the tensor
product of this vector done P times okay
so if you lower now look at this big
matrix which is n to the P cross K K is
also like N to the P okay so this matrix
is going to be non singular in fact you
can bound you can know about the minimum
singular value by something that is
inverse polynomial then as long as K is
at most N to the P over 2 this 2 is not
important as long as it is at most 1
minus epsilon times n to the P so this
is what we will show with very high
probability so this will show that the
flattening trick works and then you can
just use the algorithm for third order
tensors
okay
and I mean so I mean just to just to
tell you what I mean just to give you a
flavor of the kind of statement that we
need to show so what we want to show
when you're looking at two ice products
okay it's just to show that you take
this column you take tensor products of
these vectors so these are the perturb
vectors you take the ice column is a
tensor product of a I tilde and a tilde
you want to show that this matrix has
Sigma K the Sigma constant times n
square being non negligible okay so the
main issue here in showing this kind of
minimum singular value bounds is that
the perturbation is done before we take
the tensor product okay so suppose you
actually took the tensor products of a
is with itself and you looked at this
matrix and suppose you applied a random
perturbation to this whole matrix
suppose you applied a random
perturbation to the whole vector AI
tensor product with AI
okay so then it is much easier to show
these minimum singular value bonds the
problem here is that we do the
perturbation before we take the tensor
product okay so intuitively if you did
the perturbation after you took the
tensor product in each column there are
n square bits of randomness okay but
here you are doing the perturbation
first and then taking the tensor product
so you actually have only two and bits
of randomness and you're trying to argue
about an n Square dimensional space so
this is intuitively why it becomes
harder so this introduces a lot of block
dependencies okay and the technical
component is I mean in a vague sense it
is trying to show that when you take
these products of tensors so yeah if you
take the products of perturbed vectors
they almost look like random vectors in
an l squared dimensional space we're not
random vectors but they look like
perturb vectors in the N squared
dimensional space
this is the main issue the fact that you
don't have enough bits of randomness
okay and if you take higher wise
products it's only worse because you
have P times and bits of randomness and
then into the P dimensional space so
this is what we show and I mean the
technical statement that we show can be
reformulated as follows it's a clean
linear algebraic statement so the
statement is as follows so suppose you
are given any vectors a and B okay in n
dimensions and suppose you apply
Gaussian perturbations to a and B and if
you take the tensor product okay so now
this vector this tends this tensor
product of these two part of vectors
will have a reasonable projection on to
any n square by 2 dimensional subspace
of RN square so given any two vectors
you put of them and you take the tensor
product now this vector will have a
non-negligible projection onto any
subspace of constant times n square
dimension this is the high priority and
if you can show this this will show
bounds on the minimum singular value of
the matrix that we care about
oh yeah so droll is some yeah yeah it's
a mean it's actually just one over
project randoms on the subspace oh yeah
so you are fixing any n square
dimensional constant times n square
dimensional subspace okay so now you
take these n-dimensional vectors perturb
them take the tensor product okay so it
will have 1 over poly and projection
onto the subspace so if you look at the
projective projection matrix onto this
subspace and take the projection matrix
times this vector look at the too long
okay so this this value quantity is at
least inverse polynomial and with very
high priority this is why we know it can
go up to any one minus epsilon times n
square not n square I mean I'm guessing
that it can go up to 1 minus little o of
1 times n square but I don't know what
this little o phonus
I would guess that it depends on the
amount of concentration that you want
okay so this is the statement that we
will show and I mean just - this is a
side note to give I mean it's much
easier to get inverse polynomial
concentration instead of it I mean this
exponential small failure probability
just by using some anti concentration of
polynomials okay but the I mean an
additional difficulty is the fact that
we want this exponentially small failure
problem okay and I mean as I mentioned
earlier because of this block structure
this is harder to show so I mean let me
this actually let me skip some of these
things because I'm not sure I mean yeah
maybe some of these things are not as
important as a takeaway message okay so
okay so the way we go about it is by
showing that given any constant times n
square dimensional subspace we can
actually come up with a very structured
projection matrix okay and that is the
projection matrix that we will analyze
okay and in some sense you are given any
constant times n square dimensional
subspace we will come up with a
projection matrix with very nice
properties like saying that you know
some blocks of this projection matrix
are orthogonal to each other I'll have
an orthogonal component to each other
and the difficulty is income up coming
up with this very structured projection
matrix so and okay so let me skip some
of these things and
yeah you have to wonder is such so
similarly you can show this result for
higher order products as well and this
is why we get these results for higher
order tensors okay and the way we could
go boarded is by doing a very delicate
inductive argument and just to summarize
so we introduce a smooth analysis model
for tensity compulsions and learning and
we gave polynomial time algorithms when
the rank is much larger than the
dimension and this allowed us to get
learning to learning algorithms as well
so polynomial time algorithms for
learning when the number of clusters is
any polynomial in the dimension and
there's some future directions so I
think smooth analysis seems to be I mean
I mean at least intuitively it looks
like a nice analogue for generic results
okay and it'll be very nice if you can
show smoother analysis yourselves for
three tensors when the rank goes up to
constant times n square for example from
the results of chianti knee and ratafia
knee we know that you know they are
unique up to rank being n square by 3
perhaps you can show this uniqueness in
a smooth analysis sense as well
and right oh and I mean those are
uniqueness results similarly there are
polynomial time algorithms due to
Cardoso de la tower and who who give
algorithms for fourth order tensors for
ranked going up to N squared and it'd be
nice to show that and these are generic
results okay but they are not robust and
it'll be nice to show that you can get
algorithms that go up to this rank in a
smooth analysis sense and and I mean I
guess I mean I guess one thing that you
know I mean that was asked in the first
talk of the session was you know as
algebraic geometers how you could
potentially contribute to in these kind
of discussions and I mean somehow from
our experience from the uniqueness of
salt for the crystal theorem robust
crystal theorem and from these results
we were able to basically go through
these proofs and because these proofs
were very linear algebraic we were able
to translate a lot of these arguments
and make them robust so I mean I'm not
sure if this is possible I mean it's
elevate but I mean I said I mean it
would actually be a lot more helpful if
some of these arguments that mean with
which you can show these genetic results
could be made more linear algebraic some
sense mean I don't know what this means
but I mean linear algebraic argument
seemed a lot more easier to translate to
robust results and yeah and yeah I mean
it'll also be nice to get results which
are more robust to errors dependence in
on errors is fairly bad and if you get a
better dependence with respect to the
error that we can tolerate then you can
get better sample complexity bounds on
the kind of the sauce
we had several questions really not
maybe just to try to answer your last
comment
unfortunately algebra geometry it's
about two nonlinear question and that is
true no linear is essentially equivalent
to move time in here I mean in the sense
that for instance if I think there is an
increasing problem a I don't think it's
possible to reduce all tense of the
composition to just a linear algebra for
any so there is an increasing clear a I
mean for instance the other great basis
and a lot of polynomial techniques that
can be handled but also they told
yesterday we saw some tense or the
composition found with MATLAB but using
a given a basis approach we just to be a
little more concrete about four you're
saying for instance the algorithms that
we were able to get for higher order
tensors the reason they worked is
because generically we knew that by
taking tensor product of these vectors
this matrix is non-singular this we knew
generically and this is a statement
about linear independence of these
tensor product of vectors then the
non-linearity comes in because of the
tensor product of course but we could
phrase it as you know non singularity of
this particular matrix then we were able
to analyze and then yeah we were able to
show that in a smooth analysis since the
minimum singular value of this matrix is
also lower bounded so
then you can use your restaurant yeah so
I mean this is just some kind of
empirical I mean on empirical yeah
can you say a few words about the last
slide when he told us a hierarchy oh
yeah sure
so there were recently there's this work
by Barack Ellen's toilet I mean because
I mean tencel decompositions essentially
I mean they can be restated as questions
over polynomials and polynomial
optimization so they treated density
compositions as a polynomial
optimization problem and they were able
to get algorithms for density
compositions where they could tolerate
very high error so for instance they
were able to tolerate constant error clr
being point one and they were still able
to meaningfully you know they were able
to give meaningful guarantees on
recovery by going to these lacell
systems of degree which is very high
Rick login so that they were able to
give quasi-polynomial time algorithms
which are able to handle constant error
I mean yeah intuitively they are arguing
about a third order tensors but they go
up to much higher order polynomials and
ensure that they can actually handle
much better noise and maybe that opens
up fish perspectives in the you know
handling much better than I mean
potentially you could you could show
some kind of a more smooth dependence
but by looking at higher order tensors
you actually get better error tolerance
and you don't necessarily need to go to
log and order tensor
you're talking about their business to
noise isn't it food we figure if this
the model of noise that you pick should
also determine which algorithm you use
which will be robust to that type of
noise and it seems that I could take
your algorithm and then say just perturb
one or two entries in the tensor that
noise model might not be good for your
free algorithm where it's like
perturbing all of the entries by a small
amount might be better right serving
before tensor and as you said so it
seems like the question about me ability
to noise really is a question of oh oh I
see so that's a good question but I
guess when we are talking about
robustness to noise it is not with
respect to the random perturbation so
the random perturbation is with terrific
respect to analysis okay so you can
think of it as a pure case order tense I
mean K rank tensor by the terms of the
decomposition were randomly perturbed
okay but the noise that we are trying to
tolerate is worst case noise so apart
from the tensor you have some you know
you may but up the entries in a worst
case sense up to some inverse polynomial
amount you know intravenous norm and we
want to handle this kind of worst-case
noise because when you take I mean the
way we get these tensors is by taking
samples and by averaging them we don't
actually know what kind of errors they
introduced into I mean what kind of
sampling errors get into these tensors I
mean perhaps by understanding the kind
of errors that come up by the sampling
you can do much better but we don't
actually know that so we assume that we
have worst case noise so arbitrary noise
up to epsilon and Frobenius norm and we
want to handle that
something about nature that's fighting
against you to give you the batteries
you could pick for instance a different
noise model where maybe the sort of core
of the tensor gets perturbed by more and
noise model and then your algorithm is
not assuming that kind of noise so maybe
it would break your algorithm so I
certainly have to know what model of
noise you're gonna yeah so in some sense
I'll put the perturbations that we
handled were inspired by the learning
applications so where you are actually
perturbing the means so this is why it
correspond to the terms of the
decomposition better you could think of
other perturbations
I mean handling other perturbations for
smooth analysis sense I mean the only
thing that you need to watch out for is
to ensure that you know I mean those
perturbations do not give you a very
general instance which is hard